only the complete absence of sex can be
considered a sexual
deviation everything else is a matter of
taste a woman should soften but not
weaken a
man a father's death is the most
important
event the more heartbreaking and
poignant loss in a man's
life
before you diagnose yourself with
depression or low
self-esteem first make sure that you are
not in fact just surrounded by
the only shame in
masturbation is the shame of not doing
it
well the more perfect a person is on the
outside the more demons they have have
on the
inside We are Never So defenseless as
when we love and never so helplessly
unhappy as when we lose the object of
Love or his
love one day in retrospect the years of
struggle will strike you as the most
beautiful masturbation is one of the
primary abodes the primary
addiction subsequent addictions Alcohol
Tobacco
morphine are only its
substitutes unexpected emotions will
never
die they are buried alive and will come
forth later in uglier
ways in the small matters trust the mind
and the large ones the
heart the secret of the human soul lies
in the psychic dramas of
childhood get to the bottom of these
dramas and healing will
come most people do not really want
freedom because Freedom involves
responsibility and most people are
frightened of respons
possibility nothing costs so much in
life as illness and ignoring an
illness the scope of one's personality
is defined by the magnitude of that
problem which is capable of driving a
person out of his
wits it is an honor to have plenty of
enemies
happiness is a child's dream fulfilled
in
maturity we do not randomly choose each
other we meet only those who already
exist in our
subconscious you do not stop looking for
strength and confidence outside but you
should look inside
yourself they have always has been
there a busy man is seldom visited by
idle
friends no flies fly to a Boiling
Pot we are so made that we can only
derive intense enjoyment from a contrast
and only very little from a state of
things limitation
in the possibility of enjoyment raises
the value of the
enjoyment maturity is the ability to
postpone
gratification a man is sometimes more
generous when he has little money than
when he has much perhaps to keep from
thinking he has none at
all history is just new people making
old
mistakes the most important part of your
life is to understand yourself from the
inside we adults don't understand
children because we don't understand our
own childhood
anymore from error to error one
discovers the entire truth
truth out of your vulnerabilities will
come your
strength the first indication of
stupidity is a complete lack of
Shame a joke is the shortest way from
one person to
another a man should not strive to
eliminate his complexes but to get into
Accord with them they are legitimately
what directs his conduct in the
world friendship is an art of keeping
distance while love is an art of
intimacy he who knows how to wait need
make no
concessions human's intrinsic nature
manifests in its
misunderstandings every normal person is
really only partly
normal the best fights are the ones we
don't
fight the only person with whom you have
to compare ourselves is that you in the
past and the only person better you
should be this is who you are now
dreams are never concerned with
trivia Envy is destructive don't be
tempted by it live by your own
[Music]
rules the ego is not master in its own
house nothing is past the
unconscious
conscience is the internal perception of
the rejection of a particular wish
operating in
us the weakness of my position does not
imply a strengthening of
yours recognizing a problem is half the
success in solving
it people are more moral than they think
and far more immoral than they can
imagine being entirely honest with
oneself is a good
exercise how bold one gets when one is
sure of being
loved the voice of the intellect is
quiet but it never tires of
repeating and listeners are fine
rather than living Our Lives we are
lived by unknown and uncontrollable
forces love in the form of longing and
deprivation lowers the
self-regard a woman will never want sex
with a man who doesn't get her
hints
we seek more to take suffering away from
ourselves than to gain
pleasure the first human who hurled an
insult instead of a stone was the
founder of
civilization the mind is like an iceberg
it floats with 17th of its bulk above
water those who have eyes to see and
ears to hear will soon convince
themselves that Mortals cannot hide any
secret the energetic and successful man
is the one who succeeds in transforming
the fantasies of Desire into
reality thought is action in
rehearsal the profound obscurity of the
background of our ignorance is scarcely
illuminated by a few glimmers of
insight the virtuous man contents
himself with dreaming that which the
Wicked Man does an actual
life perfect Eternal hate purified love
exists only between the addict and the
drug
words call forth effects and are the
universal means of influencing human
beings if a woman no longer wants sex
it's a sign that soon she may start
questioning her emotional connection
with her male partner reflecting on
unfulfilled needs or unresolved issues
in the
relationship dogs love their friends and
bite their enemies quite unlike people
who are incapable of pure love and
always have to mix love and
hate love and work work and
love that's all there
is public self is a conditioned
construct of the inner psychological
self
originally the ego includes everything
later it detaches from itself the
external
World there is no need in childhood as
strong as the need for a father's
protection we are what we are because we
have been what we have
been
a woman who lacks sex begins to talk
more about sex who lacks sex speaks
about sex hungry talks about food a
person who has no money about money and
our oligarchs and bankers talk about
morality dreams are often most profound
when they seem the most
crazy no one who shares a delusion ever
recognizes it as
such civilized society is perpetually
menaced with
disintegration through this primary
hostility of men towards one
another nothing that is mentally our own
can never be
lost with words one man can make another
blessed or drive him to
despair everyone owes nature a
death experience teaches us that the
world is not a
nursery if youth knew if age
could every man must find out for
himself in what particular fashion he
can be
saved we enter the world with
loneliness and lonely leave
it